we begin in the occupied West Bank where
Israeli settlers have attacked
Palestinian property after four Israelis
were shot dead near an illegal
settlement the Israeli Army says the
shooting happened at a petrol station
and two Palestinian suspects were killed
Hamas says the attackers were linked to
its military Wing the qasan brigades
Israel says is deploying more troops to
the occupied West Bank altazira's Harry
Fawcett reports from Ramallah
another burst of killing in a bloody
year so far a Palestinian man gunned
beside him lying dead at a petrol
station on the main north-south road
through the occupied West Bank the
Israeli military said he was one of at
least two attackers who shot into a
group of Israeli settlers
I saw him going to a car where a man was
sitting he shot around at him I opened
the door I already got around into the
Chamber of the weapon at the Eli
Junction I opened the door shot him he
shot me he didn't stop moving I didn't
stop shooting
later Israeli forces surrounded a taxi
north of the city of Nablus shooting dad
a second Palestinian man injuring the
taxi driver
I picked him up he asked me to take him
to Janine hospital and we got to hear
that the Israeli Jeep stopped us I don't
know the guy
Hamas said the two men belonged to its
armed Wing saying they'd carried out a
heroic response to a large-scale Israeli
raid on the occupied West Bank City of
Janine on Monday in which at least six
Palestinians were killed and scores
wounded eight Israeli soldiers were also
injured Israel's far-right security
minister visiting the scene of the
attack demanded a yet wider scale
military response
to return to targeted assassinations
from the air take down buildings set up
roadblocks Deport Palestinian assailants
and passed the second and third readings
of the law to impose the death penalty
on terrorists
benvir wasn't invited though to the
prime minister's security consultations
to decide on that response Benjamin
Netanyahu promising to keep all options
open but seen as unlikely to sanction
the kind of escalation his security
minister wants
this year has seen the Grim pattern
emerge ever more deadly Israeli military
action along with an increased number of
often individual Palestinian shooting
attacks endorsed in retrospect by the
fighting factions already more than 170
Palestinians and at least 27 Israelis
have been killed those numbers similar
to the whole of the previous year
and the violence persisted into the
night settlers once again attacking
Palestinian property in the town of
huwara one of several outbreaks of
settler violence there's plenty of fuel
for these Flames little Prospect for now
of extinguishing them Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera Ramallah in the occupied West
Bank
a funeral has been held for one of the
suspected Palestinian attackers involved
in the petrol station shooting near the
illegal settlement of Eli the
Palestinian group Hamas says the attack
was a natural response to Growing
Israeli aggression either Ibrahim is in
Jamaine in the occupied West Bank and
explains the impact that illegal
settlements have on Villages there
many Palestinians try to invite
foreigners to see the reality for
themselves and we're here overlooking
one of the settlements let me show you
this is the illegal Israeli settlement
of Ariel
not only is it taking the lands of
Palestinians from different different
villages
look at how much it's spreading out
around the Villages which Palestinians
eventually feel that it will prevent any
potential Palestinian State because
these settlements what they do is they
isolate the Palestinian communities
making it like small Islands here and
there making it very hard for them to
have a contiguous state that has Roads
connecting to it that has really some
sort of a continuity so when you look at
the settlement it's not only related to
the lands they take but also the
resources the infrastructure we're
sitting here on one of the largest water
systems in the occupied West Bank but
when you look at people here and I'm not
sure if the camera can show you people
have to buy water tanks and put them on
top of their houses and some even have
to buy water from external sources
Imagine This this water is originally
theirs but because there is a illegal
Israeli settlements they take up those
resources including water not only that
when we talk about growing settlements
we talk about growing settler attacks
against Palestinians the whole lives of
people changes because of those
settlements for example
The Village opposite to us is called
merda and people there used to work in
agriculture their land have been taken
their resources have been very very
limited and eventually many of them left
their professions and not only that
we've been talking to Bedouin
communities in the occupied West Bank
that were forced to leave where they are
because of the growing settler attacks